[موسيقى]
تطوف الارض حول الشمس في رحله سنويه
مقدارها 365 يوما تقريبا وبناء على ذلك
فان مكان وزمان شروق وغروب الشمس يتغير
بشكل يومي فتتعامد الشمس على مدار سرطان
عند وصولها الى اقصى ميل لها ناحيه الشمال
اطول يوما بسنه وتتعامد على مدار الجدي
عند وصولها الى اقصى ميل لها ناحيه الجنوب
اطول ليله بالسنه وبينهما تتعامد على خط
الاستواء يتساوى في طول الليل مع النهار
وبعد اربعين يوما تتعامد شمس على مدار
السرطان ومدار السرطان يمر على سلطنه عمان
والامارات والسعوديه وحين ذاك سنعيش اطول
نهر واقصر ليالي السنه الا ليت النهار
يعود ليلا فان الصبح ياتي بالهموم حوائج
لا تطيق قضاء ولا ردا وردعان الغريمي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والشمس الان وصلت منتصف المسافه بين خط
الاستواء ومدار السرطان وفي اثناء مسيرها
تمر على اليمن وجنوب السعوديه على شكل
تعامد بمعنى ان ظل الزوال سيختفي على
اليمن وجنوب السعوديه وين على عسير وابها
والباحث وهذا يكون مرتين بسنه والشمس
طالعه فوق مثل هالايام والشمس نازله تحت
بعد شهرين تقريبا الظل يرقب في الدروب
خطايا واناه زادت عن حدودي انايا ظل انا
والامنيات حقيقتي ابكي ويبحث عن صداه
بكايه
[موسيقى]